welcome back to las vegas now august 6
will be essentially the best night
because that's when daniel emma and pia
toscano are taking the stage at the
international theater at the west gate
and they are here with us today to tell
us all about the show how are you guys
good
fantastic thank you so much for having
us here today we're really excited about
this show tell us a little bit about it
what can people expect when they come
into the theater
well i think what they can expect is a
night full of classic duets from across
the generations and genres of music
we are just so excited to be presenting
this brand new show at westgate and it's
going to be a night of fun for all ages
and it's
just the best duets we know and we're
going to have a lot of fun doing them it
was hard coming up with the set list
because there are so many great duets
there's so many great songs so we've had
a lot of fun putting it together and
have you guys performed together or how
did this relationship become about we've
watched each other a lot we both perform
in the david foster tour
but yeah this is going to be the first
time for us this is our first full show
together oh my gosh it's going to be
great well you guys have great chemistry
so i'm sure that will translate onto the
stage and why the name simply the best
where did that come from well it
honestly went as we're putting the show
together that's what we kept calling it
we're just doing simply the best duets
and uh not to spoil anything but that
iconic song simply the best just might
be in the show
i love that song that is the song that i
walked down the aisle to you at my
weddings
[Music]
it's been having a moment after we
started talking about doing it in the
show but i've been hearing it in
commercials all of a sudden again and as
you know it's not a song that's
traditionally a duet and that's
something we're also doing with our show
is taking songs that weren't necessarily
duets to begin with and turning them
into something new so you're putting a
fun spin on the classic songs and i mean
between america's got talent and
american idol you guys are so beyond
talented and really quickly i was dying
the other night when i'm watching
america's got talent and you came back
up such a cool act um how was that to be
back on that stage you know being able
to go home to america's got talent was
incredibly special but not only getting
to go home but to go home and become the
singing voice of simon cowell it was
amazing better than i could have ever
asked for if you guys haven't seen it go
look on youtube it's the funniest thing
i've ever seen but it's just so great
that you guys got kind of your start on
those shows and now look where you are
now you're out here in vegas so really
excited for this show and if people want
to get tickets or do you know where they
can go to to come check you guys out
absolutely they can go to westgatelas
vegas.com or to ticketmaster.com and
then get tickets online they are
available and they s and they are going
faster
well we're so excited for you guys
danielle thank you for being here you
guys really are simply the best that's
my favorite song right now so i'm really
excited about this so be sure all the
information is on your screen that's
happening this saturday august 6th
simply the best at night of d west at
the international theater at the west
gate las vegas now we'll be right back